well good friday morning everybody from
a las vegas headliners battle in court
to a cheesy valentine's day gift let's
head on over to the mix 94.1 studio
to check in with las vegas now host
mercedes martinez
for a look at what's trending today
happy friday martinez
thank you so much good morning
we begin with britney spears she had a
small victory in court yesterday she is
trying to remove her father
as her conservator and yesterday a judge
denied her dad's objections to how her
conservatorship
will be delegated now he wanted the
judge to remove the co-conservatory
which is a financial institution but the
judge said
no spears only wants the company in
charge of her estate
another hearing is scheduled next month
but brittney did send a message
to fans this week amid the buzz around
her conservatorship and that new
documentary framing britney spears
she said i am taking the time to learn
and be
a normal person from brittany to
another pop star taylor swift the singer
and april 9th are trending because
fans think that's when she's going to
release the re-recorded version
of her album fearless now she wrote this
note to fans on twitter
it was all lowercase except for a few
letters
which spelled out april 9. sherry
i know you're a swifter swifty aren't
you
i like taylor swift a lot and and i'm
also getting back to that documentary
mercedes
i heard it's pretty brutal too and very
revealing about
uh britney spears so i really want to
watch that that's on my to watch list
have you seen it yet
yes i watched it it's on hulu it is
really eye-opening and i think it's made
a lot of people really rethink out how
they
treated her back in the 2000s it's it's
definitely worth the watch
good good all right well mercedes tell
us about how people can
show their love for cheese on this
valentine's day man
check this out tillamook is selling this
40
pound block of sharp yellow cheddar
for national cheddar day which is
tomorrow now it's been dubbed
the mother loaf of cheese tillamook says
the the cheese is aged in these blocks
anywhere from 60 days to 10 years
the mother loaf it costs a hundred and
twelve dollars
and they're only selling 25 of them
so sherry if you are a huge cheese fan
you have to set your alarm for for eight
o'clock tomorrow morning
that's when sales begin online that
would be a perfect valentine's gift to
someone you care about or for yourself
well i always thought i was a big cheese
fan i didn't think i was a
huge cheese fan my question is mercedes
who's got a fridge big enough for a 40
pound block of cheese come on where are
you gonna put that
i have no idea and the weather's been so
nice i'd be afraid of leaving it outside
for fear that it might melt a little bit
i think it'd be moldy i think it'd be
moldy real fast but it's fun
make your own nachos outside or
something for the whole neighborhood
all right mercedes thank you so much for
joining us and we always look forward to
seeing you on las vegas now right here
on channel 8. happy valentine's day you
too take care
okay oh wow too much cheese for me guys
yeah it's it's a little overkill you can
be a big fan of cheese not a fan of big
cheese
yes that's a all right thanks mercedes
that's great